i did empty from iit bombay i am working
in the ingersoll ranch but as a
technical manager from 2017.
decision of upskilling myself
in the field of data science did wonder
and due to expertise i gained
from the aiml course
i got promoted in 2022.
hi i am
i did postgraduation in artificial
intelligence and machine learning from
simply learn
and i am handling the projects
related to iot data analytics
while working as a technical manager
back in 2020
i felt limitations in my skill set
and artificial intelligence and machine
learning are evolving field
and
upskilling was necessary to keep me up
to date with the skill set the content
whatever i have found on the youtube was
not comprehensive then i started
searching the online course i chose this
course because of rich content it follow
the best practices
and it is perfect fit for me
certifications from purdue university
was added advantage
my learning experience was enriching
since class was live and interactive i
never felt bored complex concept that
they have explained very easily i am
thankful to all the instructors who were
clearing my doubts during the class also
classes were on weekend i didn't face
any challenge related to work timing and
i was having the ample amount of time to
spend the timing with the family and my
wife was very supportive my company
supports employee for further study they
sponsored the entire course the
certification was a great boost for me
when i needed it it gave me the great
visibility in my organizations
and even vice president of my
organizations acknowledged my work i
look forward to upskill myself
as this is the best investment anyone
can make keep learning success is
guaranteed